what's up guys bang bang it is lunch
money time
polina is here so am i and blockfight is
the sponsor which means you should go
sign up for a blockfy account
you can go to blockfy.com and sign up
for a blockfi account at that account
you can earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account you
can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
and you can take out the us dollar loan
and get your crypto collateral if you
want to be cool
like me go to blockby.com
okay all right coinbase shares
changed hands at a roughly 90 90 billion
dollar value last week
in what could be the final chance for
investors to trade its private stock
before the crypto exchange goes public
the valuation is based on 350 a share
the price the stock was trading at on
the nasdaq private market auction
wow so do we think this ipo is going to
be massive why so low
oh come on it was trading at over 100
billion a couple weeks ago was it
yes it was 375
earlier in auction which would value it
close to 100 billion well maybe it went
down maybe no it was over
it was over it was over a hundred this
thing's gonna hit the market and it's
gonna
pop it's gonna be coinbase goes public
everyone wants crypto and the stimulus
hits at the same time
it's like the tailwind of all tailwinds
150 billion dollar market cap
market check the receipts 150 billion
dollar market cap in the first week
you heard it here first that's my
prediction
nydig uh the firm that facilitated mass
mutual's 100 million dollar bitcoin by
last year
has raised 200 million dollars from a
cadre of big
name investors including stone ridge
holdings
morgan stanley new york life mass mutual
sora
soros
and fs investments best of our venture
partners and fintech collective
also participated wow why are these
people so interested
everyone's interested in bitcoin you
know why because we have an
undisciplined monetary policy where
literally
the government the elected officials in
the federal reserve have lost
their minds these people are insane
and they're on twitter trying to
convince all of us and they're in the
press trying to convince all of us
that inflation is less than one percent
get out of here
didn't even the fed chairman say that
it's not
it's not two percent isn't accurate he
said all the unofficial numbers yeah
wait a minute if you are going to
acknowledge the unofficial numbers then
why do we have official numbers
which one's right the unofficial or the
official because of the unofficial
numbers say we got six to ten percent
inflation and guess what if you're in
the lowest socioeconomic classes
inflation is eating your wealth you're
literally getting pushed further and
further into a
desperate dire financial position while
the rich get richer why is the stock
market up why is bitcoin up why are all
the assets
pumping on the news that money's coming
because the rich
get richer when they pump money into the
system
paypal has agreed to acquire
israel-based curve a provider of
cloud-based infrastructure for digital
asset security
financial terms of the deal were not
disclosed but the payments giant
said it plans to use the new purchase to
accelerate and expand its initiatives to
support cryptocurrencies and digital
assets wait can i can i say something
when we first started doing lunch money
on april 1st last year because i don't
count
his first episode by himself i count
when i was there so when we first
started doing it and i was
looking at the topics it was very hard
to find bitcoin related
topics because there weren't a lot we
just had like one topic a day now it's
like the whole thing is
crypto do you know why why because
exactly what i said
last year what what is today's date
today is march 9th on march 12th is when
i wrote the big one last year i said
when the liquidity crisis
because i have a good memory everybody
knows this
march 12th 2020 i wrote a piece i said
we're in a liquidity crisis the
government's going to step in they're
going to bring their bazookas
i think is the term that i used and they
are going to flood the market with
liquidity and it's going to pump asset
prices and bitcoin's going to do better
than all the other assets
news flash that's what's happened if you
had listened to me you'd be in a better
position
but the whole world has gone on a fomo
they've gone on a global
scavenger hunt trying to figure out how
can they protect themselves from these
undisciplined insane monetary policy
think about paypal and curve
i think that there's a missed
opportunity for a headline i was hoping
that curve was going to have
conversations
and then not do the acquisition so then
so then they could say
curve curved paypal and
didn't participate but you know paypal
got the job done good job paypal paypal
is not going to leave crypto or bitcoin
now they have a custodian goldman sachs
is seeing substantial demand for digital
assets from institutions
as it works to restart its
cryptocurrency trading desk
in a survey of nearly 300 clients by the
firm
40 percent currently have exposure to
crypto
listen i think we'd cover this topic but
goldman
goldman wants everybody trading that's
what happens
everybody wants in on the game
everybody wants to know the game
everybody wants in on the game we're out
of sync
because wall street's not gonna sit
by and watch the world
burn while bitcoiners are right so guess
what they're gonna do
they're no longer gonna argue that
bitcoins are wrong they're just gonna
become bitcoiners and they're gonna
jump in the game rob gronkowski
is entering the digital collectible
space and releasing his own nfts
the national football league tight end
partnered with non-fundable tokens
marketplace openc to release five
digital trading cards featuring super
bowl
moments i personally like this idea yeah
yeah gronk who don't like grunk
everybody likes gronk
imagine if you could own a gronk
moment whether it's him shirtless on the
boat
wiggling his hips
or it's him grabbing the rock one handed
with a little toe tap in the back of the
end zone
or it's gronk just winding up with a big
spike
in the end zone everybody loves gronk
lez roll
i would not be buying it though ah
right hold on
up clean is not ready please it's not
right i was catching up on my
correspondence it's ask
lunch money time ask lm
in the comments below we got two
questions and a moist update
first question rick would you rather
skydive or bungee trump
go first skydive same time should we go
no
you won't go with me no why no why not
because i'm scared joe would you rather
skydive or bungee jump
i've done one but not the other which
one did you do
skydiving oh my brother's here but he's
too scared to come on the camera
so what would you do you should go if
you follow my brother at joe pompliano
on twitter you should unfollow him
because he's being a loser he won't come
on the camera sign up for his newsletter
no no don't sign up he's thinking about
it he's thinking about walking over here
if you come over here i'll give you free
marketing if you come get on the camera
huddle up that substance he's not
dedicated he doesn't actually care
followup.substack.com while you're at it
the profile that's upset
okay let's go to the next um so this is
from
a my bulgarian friend friend so i'm
going to say his name in bulgarian
because i don't want to like butcher it
in english
no hi you're so you're literally the
worst human
okay hi from bulgaria anybody else's
wife think that
i'm from bulgaria ponca paulina i would
love to be working in crypto but i'm not
a programmer you recently launched the
crypto jobs platform i need advice where
to learn programming or what else i can
learn to be involved in this
generational change for seven years i've
been working in a social advertising
company what's your advice
would you please recommend a platform i
can learn coding and crypto i can do
this
after and before my boring regular job
and while my baby uh oh it cut me off i
think
sleeps maybe you don't need to learn
programming
if you know how to do social media
there's plenty of companies that need
help with social media
there's plenty of people that need help
with advertising there's plenty of
people that need help with pr
with analytics with growth marketing
uh with product with design
right all these are operations customer
service all that stuff
people need help it's not just
programmers so if you got a skill
don't worry about having to go and learn
how to code
or do anything else just take your skill
and go and apply there's plenty of roles
open
pomcryptojobs.com there's literally been
over 15
000 job applications have been submitted
on there a lot of different people have
already been hired
and you can either have roles that are
in person
or remote so there's plenty of jobs on
there and who knows
maybe i need someone to do some social
media you never know so go on
check it out and apply do you wanna
tell him what you know in bulgarian i
know a lot in bulgarian
or beach bulgaria all right
for those for those that you don't speak
bulgaria that means i love bulgaria i
was surprised you didn't say
pauline won't leave me alone but oh
that's pulling it uh
that means you look beautiful all right
because i like your hair
what does it mean beautiful hair um
moist counter day uh
i think 19. okay what is going on with
moist yesterday was moist day 18.
day 18 of commenting in my experience
because i'm such a catch the girl is the
first one to express
interest in seeing the cool stuff in my
apartment at the end of the first date
if she is a ruth steakhouse type of girl
i'll show her but with the mcdonald's
type
type of girls i have a busy morning the
next day i need to get them betterly
moist
let me just tell you something moist
that's a trick question because to him
i was a mcdonald's type of girl but
that's a that's a highest
of compliments because wait why because
because where are you going with this
because
you lost in the sauce right now because
mcdonald's
is the oh like can she hang at
mcdonald's because if she can't if she's
only a ruth steakhouse type of girl i
don't think he won that high
um well you're you're missing the whole
point of work
[Music]
said because i'm such a catch the girl
is the first one to express
interest in seeing the cool stuff at my
apartment at the end of the first date
all right dan you you uh you you don't
waste no time moist
i like it i like it today we have a
question for you
from my very dear friend caroline
hennigar she would like to know
she would like this is a guest question
she would like to know
do you believe in ghosts why or why not
be careful be careful this is a a very
difficult trick question
i'm not participating in this question
this is a stupid question
everybody knows ghosts ain't real we're
not gonna don't give away moist
moist that's a trick answer as well all
right thank you you're not
you you fool people like me and moist
you can't
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click
on i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind paulina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest
on an interest-bearing account or you
can buy and sell cryptocurrencies on
their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find up to 8.6 interest on
a deposit in an interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends